sit the one-and-only back she's back and
doing better than ever
Kathie Lee Gifford stops by her old
stomping grounds on the fourth hour of
The Today Show for a visit
Gifford glowed as she told her former
co-host Hoda Kotb and Jenna Bush Hager
about her happy new life in Music City
Kathie Lee is happier now then I
remember her being in years and years
and years it's a culture of kindness
yeah and that's I mean I and they're
authentically kind yeah Kathie Lee also
came ready to dish about her dating life
you know with friends to a club and it's
this sweet guy asked me to dance and so
I said okay now he just went out a
couple of times the former Today Show
host shared that she hadn't been on a
date in 33 years Gifford was married to
Frank Gifford for 29 years until his
death in 2015 in 2018 Kathie Lee told et
that it was her late husband that
convinced her to take the Today Show
opportunity with Hoda yeah I had no
interest in going back to television
he helped me see that it wasn't a going
backwards it was going forward to
something different with Hoda
you know then I he was right he said
just sign for a year she stayed for 11
before announcing her departure in 2018
I'm gonna be leaving The Today Show in
2015 Hoda told et about her special bond
with Kathie Lee we have a thing where I
think every now and then unlike you meet
someone and it clicks just like two
puzzle pieces and we found each other of
course some things have changed since
Kathie Lee's departure as she quickly
learned this I'm sorry I'm gonna need to
see is this wine remember we can't allow
wine into the studio I'm sorry
[Music]